last weekend trump was going after me at
his rallies he
got a big bug up his ass about something
i said on my show a week ago about
desantis being a better president and so
he started and i lived through this like
when he was president he had an
eight-month period where it was ever he
you know he he's like a comic book he
does a chunk in his act right he had a
chunk about me he sees that it works so
just like us as comics the chunk works
we're going to keep it in right so for
months and months it was just about this
maniac says i'm not gonna leave if i
lose well who turned out to be right
about that
okay
so he had a big chunk about that and so
then he started one last saturday about
yes i said desantis would be better
because he's not completely crazy
and then he he called me a radical
left-wing maniac which is not true and
he said uh
fox i said he's always laughing at fox
news okay true i am doing that and then
he said and fox news kisses my ass which
isn't pretty
uh so i tweeted about that because
and when he said there he's booked on
fox news well i wasn't booked on foxes
he just made that up i know someone like
donald trump to just make something up
but uh so i wanted it out there that no
i'm not [ __ ] booked on fox news but i
want to be i've tried to be and now
because of that and because i tweeted
about it now i am booked on foxes now we
are negotiating and i'm going to do
tucker carlson i'd love to i mean he
offered me before tucker carlson then i
said absolutely right away and then they
came back and said
yeah but just let's just talk about the
things we agree about i'm like no
why are you having what sort of stupid
way is that to have an interview no
we'll talk about everything yes there
are some things we will agree about
there's a reason why fox news puts me on
their website and that's what drives
trump crazy is because i'm not afraid to
go after the left when they're wrong and
they're wrong a lot these days but i
have perspective about who's more crazy
i cannot wait uh i can't wait either
[Music]